yes good I could just like jump Wow
you gonna keep doing that you can play
with it above the table I feel like that
okay
not like a we're you asked for this Wow
take me take me to the side hello
everybody my name is markiplier and I'm
back with Bob for skate three yeah you
sound a little more excited about that's
my sincere celebration
I've seen okay actually that is yeah so
um draw me
yeah draw me like one of your swedish
alternate ending dude Titanic [ __ ] you
ocean well thou gonna get you and he
crushed his nuts so he died Oh
[Laughter]
skateboard come here another real
skating began you believe that worked
I didn't know this was navigation
simulator 6,000 no that's too
just cuz you said good doughnut no I
like it hurts down deep in my lungs I
think it's ripping apart all my aerials
you know what I'm talking about what the
god the aerial is that oh that's what
you're talking about
is that part of your nipple is that what
that is
no no throwing marks nipples yeah by now
you guys have all seen the video that we
made oh god it was so much fun Bob
actually came in got off the plane
waited around the airport for everyone
to come pick me up as soon as I can in
the car the first thing it's like all
right we got so much stuff to do we're
gonna go get some donuts and wait to go
to gamestop we didn't prepare for your
arrival at all so we gotta buy
everything we're about to do
oh and then we're gonna go home and
everyone's gonna touch you and we're
gonna videotape it well I know we didn't
talk to you about this previously even
though we were been planning it and we
just assumed you'd be on board dude you
were so into it like as soon as we said
the idea yes was acting Oh inside I was
absolutely mortified you know I would
say that was the single weirdest thing
I've ever done the best part it's it's
this very subtle lighting thing that
bloom that happening yeah yeah and it's
what makes it look cool but it's not it
was like it was ghetto rigged yeah yeah
so it was just Daniel flipping a switch
and he had to time it perfectly and
every time it was just like there are
three two one
all right touch Bob for 30 seconds
Oh do it again Gary start over everyone
get back in your Bob touching position
exactly get to move just I just for that
whole 30 minutes or hours I just stood
still like good stencil you whenever you
are we saw you were enjoying it will
baby on the outside you know no place
sucks skating game what do you expect oh
yeah we know this one yeah everyone
remember this that's good when you play
that will be my laughs that's your funny
happens oh no the Ministry of funny
laughs can we start that mrs. Lipton
ministry of
yeah it was a parody off of that idea
what happened
i Oh God I broke only the middle of my
Wow all of the rest of me is perfectly
fine when you die you just respawn Oh Oh
God yeah so that video where everyone's
touching me are you just trying to like
get yourself in there your balls are all
slowly roll don't see me Larry could
have a skateboard
I would I know the guy who made it oh I
was talking so I can Holly get it I
could probably
[Music]
nice pretty good Oh God nice
oh oh it's uneasy that's right I can't
land sideways and it's all Oh
Zadie good good good yeah it was he was
rolling I've totally forgotten how to
play no no yeah thank you very much yeah
yeah [ __ ] what are you trying to do
[ __ ] how do I go backwards you have
no idea what I'm about to do it's gonna
be so funny so poor you've done that
like 12 No take it take
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]